I know it's infuriating when
anyone presents both sides of an issue
and says: "let the audience decide".
And I don't really like doing meta stuff
where I talk about
the process of making videos,
but I can't find any other way
to give enough context
to make this video work.
Hence the "come for a walk with me
through a rough bit of the English
countryside" GoPro camera shot.
It's important to break the format
visually as well.
I've been sharing videos from around
Germany, Austria and Switzerland
over the past couple of weeks.
One of the first things I filmed on
that trip was the
radon tunnel, the "radonstollen", in Bad
Kreuznach in south-west Germany.
The video should have gone out weeks ago.
But despite filming
going really well on location, despite
being really happy with my script
and the interview at the time,
I just wasn't comfortable with it
when I got back here to the UK.
Radon, or "rad-don" if you're German,
is a colorless, odorless, radioactive gas
that's produced naturally by uranium decay.
All around the world, tiny tiny
amounts of it seep out from
wide areas of the ground and get diluted
into the atmosphere harmlessly.
But if your house is in a particularly bad
radon area, like here in Oxfordshire,
then you can get detectors installed
or tests done to check that
radon isn't building up inside your house
and exposing you to too much radiation.
Which is why I was surprised
that there are a few places in the world
where people go to be exposed to radon
deliberately for pain relief.
So: the radon tunnel in Bad Kreuznach.
- It is a tunnel that was founded 1775.
People tried to find mercury here.
They dug for mercury.
They did never find mercury, but round about
110 years ago, they found radon.
The dose is, per one hour treatment,
between 30-60 thousand bequerels.
On average you need
ten treatments, one hour.
At the end, the application will have
a dose of around about 2.2 millisieverts.
To give you an idea
what is the equivalent:
if you have, for instance,
X-rays of your hip or your knee,
it is more or less the same, equivalent.
A complete CT of the complete body
has about between 20 and 40 millisieverts.
- Every medically trained person
that I've talked to about radon therapy,
they've all gone through the same
three stages that I did.
First of all, complete skepticism,
"oh, that sounds like a bad idea".
Certainly, most of the world
would consider deliberate exposure
to radioactive gas for pain relief
as alternative medicine.
That's what I did.
And then stage two.
You look at the scientific papers
and, yes, the marketing,
that talk about what limited trials
there have been, and the patient
testimonials, and the theories about why
it works, and the reaction becomes...
agh, I guess maybe it's worth a look?
But there's a conflict
of interest declaration in that paper.
But it says the funders had no say
in the results or the release.
And there is almost a folk belief
in some parts of the nuclear industry,
particularly in the US, about something
called "radiation hormesis", where
very small doses of radiation
can have a beneficial effect, they think,
because they cause repair systems
in your body to kick into action.
But that is an idea, a hypothesis.
It's not even really a theory yet.
It's not been properly tested.
All the major international authorities
say that it's entirely unproven
and there isn't really any truly safe
dose of radiation.
And yet, radon therapy seems
to work for a lot of people.
So then you've reached the third stage:
not knowing how to even talk about this
responsibly.
That's where I'm at.
I've met the people who run a radon tunnel.
I've talked to a patient.
I've got a duty of care to them,
as I do to anyone I film with.
But I also have a duty to the audience
and to the truth: scientific
or historical or personal.
So I need to make something very clear.
This is not an endorsement.
I think radon therapy is fascinating.
The people who run the radon spa
definitely think it works.
Certainly, most of their patients do.
There's just enough evidence here
that this unqualified skeptic
can't write it off, not immediately.
And the fact that there's all this
infrastructure for handling radioactive gas
as part of something that
most of the world hasn't even heard of?
Well, I think that's interesting enough
to at least discuss.
- Just to make clear:
it is not "wellness", it's not miracles.
We do not promise something weird.
It is pure medicine.
It's a medical application
where you need a doctor's prescription.
And at the end, 85% of the patients,
they report it helped, it worked.
So you get rid of your medication
for pain relievers for one year and more.
It is not wellness. That's really...  it must be clear.
Obviously, to get a license for this,
especially in Germany,
it's a really huge
and complicated process,
and therefore we have to prove
that the minimum application of the doses
is not below 30,000Bq and the maximum dose
is never above 100,000Bq.
We are always, in the average,
somewhere between
30-60 thousand, which is a perfect range
for the treatment.
- There are plenty of doctors
and health insurance companies in Germany
that endorse radon therapy,
but that isn't evidence for it working.
The British National Health Service paid
for some homeopathic treatments
until 2017, despite a mountain of evidence
proving that homeopathy does
absolutely nothing.
Homeopathy may feel like it works
for some people, but if you just
give people a sugar pill, a placebo,
and say "it'll help with your pain",
a lot of the time feels like it does help,
at least for the short term.
The placebo effect isn't quite as magical
as some folks think,
but certainly very powerful for sensations
like pain and nausea...
the sort of things
that radon therapy is intended to treat.
But the trouble is that radon spas aren't
like homeopathy or like magnet therapy.
They're not popular enough
to have been comprehensively tested.
Anecdotes are not evidence for something
medical, particularly when radiation is involved.
The warning signs  of quackery, of fake medicine, are:
bold claims about miracle cures;
single interventions that claim to help
wildly different conditions;
or explanations
that defy the laws of physics.
It's not guaranteed to be quackery
if you've got those, of course,
but those are the warning signs.
In other parts of the world, radon
therapy is much less regulated.
In Montana, USA, say, there are old radon-filled
mines that just charge admission to go sit inside.
And some of them make wild claims about helping
diabetes, gout, asthma, MS or even cancer.
But the claims made in Germany
are much more limited and specific.
It's just for relief of chronic pain,
and the cause of chronic pain
can often be a mystery.
And so can how to treat it.
- The treatment doesn't work instantly,
so if you leave the tunnel,
you are not instantly cured.
Patients, they report to us, normally
it takes some days, up to 6-8 weeks,
when it works.
We are aware that some other tunnels
worldwide, they claim they can cure anything.
We are pain relief,
pain relief from inflammatory process.
Not more and not less.
Normally, people think "radioactivity,
oh, that's harmful!" but it is always
the same question: it's the doses
that makes sense, and what we here apply.
You see this equipment that is monitoring
how much radon is emitted,
and we do emit radon in that quantity
that is necessary to initiate healing
processes.
- There's one line
in that big analysis paper
that says it's really difficult to do
a fully double-blind study about this.
That would be
where each patient doesn't know
if they're receiving radon or not,
and neither do the staff or the doctors.
Yes, radon is colorless and odorless, but
it's always there, coming out the ground.
You can't fool people into walking
into a somehow-identical tunnel or cabin
that you've just mysteriously constructed
next door to the old one,
but that doesn't happen
to have radon in it this time.
Except: in that one tunnel in Bad
Kreuznach, you can turn off the radon.
- This is absolutely unique,
and to my knowledge,
no other tunnel worldwide
has the same technique.
And that is why we are, today,
absolutely safe.
As you see on the monitor,
we have no radioactivity here
besides the normal activity
you have outside.
The radon gas is emitted very deep down
in that mountain
and it is naturally emitted.
At the end,
we just grab the gas with with a pipeline
and a kind of fan
that transports it into this room.
And we can switch it on and off
in the proportion we need it.
- That's why I was allowed to film
in the treatment room.
It didn't have any radon in it.
Not then, anyway.
It hadn't been used for hours.
All the ventilation meant
there was just fresh air in there.
It would absolutely be possible
to set up a proper, large-scale,
double-blind study in that tunnel.
If some university or government
wanted to fund it.
If they could find enough
willing patients.
If their ethics review board
would be willing to sign off
on treating people with radioactive gas.
And if it could be arranged that no-one,
not even the staff at the tunnel,
knew whether each patient was getting
radon therapy or just fresh air.
It would be difficult.
But it's more possible there than anywhere
else, and I want that trial to happen.
That's why I decided to talk about this
and put the video out.
That's why I'm willing to risk
giving an audience to something
that isn't proven yet,
because if that works as claimed,
even just for some people with chronic pain,
it'd be brilliant.
Very minor radiation
exposure is a risk that
a lot of people would be willing to take,
clearly are willing to take,
if they can't get pain relief
any other way.
And if it doesn't work, then we  probably
need to stop exposing people to radiation?
I know it's a cop-out to say
"more studies are required".
It's the weak ending to every inconclusive
undergraduate paper,
but in this case, it's true.
More studies are required, and hopefully
those studies will happen soon.
Because I would love to go back
to a radon spa in a few years' time
and follow up with the proof.